I always have hope Kristin Davis wasn't
planning on answering any sex in the
city three questions when she stepped
out to support the stand up for Pitts
benefit but in true Charlotte York
fashion she told ET she's staying
positive I can't have you dare not ask
about sex in the city 3 I am only
talking dogs today I have any hope any
hope today I always have hope what do
you want to see Charlotte do not know I
gave you 1 and say you went from Laura I
always have hope while we cross our
fingers and wait kristin is busy
standing up for animal rights she prays
stand up for Pitt's founder Rebecca Cory
it's because the Rebecca's mission is to
say do not discriminate against pit
bull-type dogs do not discriminate
against people stand up for each other
be kind to each other
think about what you're doing that's her
whole mission she's not somebody where
they're thinking oh look at the cute
puppy let's save him you know he's more
like I will do whatever it takes to help
these dogs
[Music]
you
[Music]